простий закон проєкт закону але не
просту тему Ми могли би зараз обговорити
але владі вигідно зараз замовчувати
насправді от зараз ми говоримо про
конкретний перелік товарів які
експортуються з України і відносно яких
є
мито експортне мито це дуже невеликий
перелік товарів і зараз приймається
закон абсолютно правильний ми його
будемо підтримувати але в цей час
існує величезна проблема на зерновому
коридорі Ви не чули про корупцію яка там
відбувається чи не пов'язані це речі
частково за цим про що ми зараз говоримо
і якраз недобір платежів чи там якісь
втрати які уже анонсовані кругом і всіма
вони не стосуються цієї норми бо зерна
тут немає вони стосуються абсолютно
невчасно прийнятих рішень або ж навпаки
прийнятих рішень які дозволили фікти
відгружати в оцьому вузькому горличку
зернового коридору величезні партії
товарів не платити в Україні жодної
копійки не платити як платник податку а
а й нейтер бо А яка експортеру у них
немає платежів але податкова беб і
митниця допустили таке провалля і не в
них зовсім мова Мені здається що згодом
всі правоохоронні органи можливо при
діючій владі можливо після них знайдуть
кінці в цій проблемі і Вони починаються
від дозволів які хтось дає для того щоб
компанія могла загрузитися на бортсудна
Мені дуже цікава ця тема мені здаюсь
Мені здається що не буде відповіді при
діючій владі на всі ці питання але до
тих пір поки не буде прозорого реєстру
всіх експортерів зернових які мають
право як кожен із любий попасти на судно
не буде толку буде Одна корупція і ніхто
ніколи не розслідує її